[Música]
pasamos a hablar de revista de prensa en
directo américa de france24 rosa pérez
más de un lista conmigo ya en el estudio
rosa mañana del jueves finalizando
semana abrimos por supuesto esta revista
de prensa con el repaso de todas las
portadas internacionales que destacan ya
un mes de lo que ha sido esta invasión
rusia a ucrania hemos hecho una
selección de ocho periódicos rosa buenos
días raúl exactamente porque en muchos
periódicos ya la portada vuelve a estar
dedicada a información nacional pero
como comentaba hay algunos que destacan
este primer mesa de guerra en ucrania
recordemos a que cuando empezó esta
invasión rusa había titulares del estilo
lo impensable o el regreso de la
historia aparte de muchos que titulaban
directamente rusia invade ucraniano un
mes de guerra después ya sea digamos en
normalizado mediáticamente un poco la
situación y encontramos en lemont
precisamente el estancamiento ruso y sus
peligros también en el medio francés
libération leemos putin reinventa
occidente luego en el periódico italiano
corriere della sera' el fantasma de las
armas químicas en relación a esta bomba
de fósforo no rusa en kiev por otro lado
el país titula kiev resiste un mes
después pues del inicio de la guerra
dice las tropas rusas avanzan en la
destrucción pero no en la ocupación del
país por otro lado hemos seleccionado
también otro periódico italiano la
repubblica que en ese sentido en citas
de lentes que al presidente de ucrania
diciendo la guerra relámpago de putin ha
fracasado también vemos en la folha de
sao paulo la foto de una herida de
mariupol no uno de los escenarios más
devastados por esta invasión rusa no que
ya lleva semanas bajo el sitio de las
tropas ruta de las tropas rusas tenemos
también el boston globe que señala la
otan duplica sus fuerzas en la frontera
y el wall street journal las bajas rusas
aumentan y nos quedamos con este
periódico raúl así es rosa porque uno de
los temas destacados en la prensa a lo
largo de este mes ha sido por supuesto
las imposiciones de las sanciones a
rusia porque junto con el envío de armas
a ucrania ha sido también una respuesta
occidente
invasión tenemos una novedad respecto a
ese tema en exclusiva como usted lo dijo
igual soy yo no exactamente este medio
estadounidense nos hizo comprender ayer
porque a diferencia de la unión europea
o de reino unido eeuu no impuso
sanciones contra roman abramovich
recordemos el propietario del chelsea
entre otras muchas propiedades como
comentábamos el otro día y es que
precisamente selenski le pidió a biden
aprendemos gracias a esta noticia que no
impusiera sanciones contra abramovich
porque es de ayuda en las negociaciones
de paz con rusia de hecho este oligarca
es el uno y el único que públicamente ha
dicho que está insistiendo al kremlin en
que restablezca la paz en ucrania lo
antes posible y al mismo tiempo gran
mitin también ha sido mentira vamos con
primero con otra información porque
otras reacciones de hecho una de las
primeras la unión europea a la guerra
fue bloquear el territorio de los medios
de rt y es bucle y ya lo jugamos que en
su querida decir de vladimir putin 2
exacto no porque en relación a las
sanciones una de las primeras medidas
fue bloquear estos medios estatales
rusos porque la prop presidenta de la
comisión europea a ursula von der leyen
los calificó de maquinaria mediática del
kremlin y lo que es cierto es que a lo
largo de este mes han avenido titulando
muchas veces con la versión oficial del
kremlin respecto por ejemplo el
bombardeo de ese hospital de mariupol
que consideraron un centro de
operaciones del comando de extrema
derecha a soft o también ese teatro no
es recientemente bombardeado que
atribuyeron a una explosión provocada
también por este comando de extrema
derecha también señalamos otro medio pro
kremlin que hace una campaña pues sin
filtros un poco de propaganda a favor de
rusia el conson no es que haya pravda
que encontramos en el artículo que
resume este primer mes de invasión dice
podríamos haber imaginado hace un mes
que tanques rusos estarían a las puertas
de kiev y liberaría mariupol de los
nazis eso es lo que leemos raúl ahora si
al mismo tiempo también vladimir putin
han puesto una fuerte de censura
mediática en su país sin embargo en
medios rusos que tratan de contrarrestar
y seguir informando a pesar de todo esto
exacto no sé si recuerdas la entrevista
con sonic el que este periodista que
abandono cuando empezó la invasión que
nos dijo que esta respuesta de putin
había sido motivada por estas sanciones
previamente impuestas por la unión
europea contra rt y sputnik pero como
comentabas no hay una censura imperante
en rusia en los medios de comunicación
pero hay medios como el nóvaya gazeta y
el kommersant que intentan de una forma
crítica pues digamos esquivar esta
censura recordemos que en nóvaya gazeta
cuando hizo referencia a la protesta de
esta productora del canal 1 de marina
oceánico va con ese cartel pues lo
publicó en su portada pero borrando la
palabra guerra la que está prohibida en
rusia para hacer referencia a la que a
lo que sucede en ucrania ahora mismo
pero precisamente estos medios junto con
el moscú time que está en manos
extranjeras por lo que también escapa un
poco a este control estatal titulan hoy
la muerte de la periodista rusa oksana
paulina precisamente en kiev cuando
reportaba pues las consecuencias de un
bombardeo ruso en la capital ucraniana y
ella misma fue víctima mortal de otro
bombardeo que está ahora mismo
investigando la fiscalía ucraniana
y rosa tras este mes de guerra como tula
x independent pues hace referencia a la
ciudad occidental de elvis que considera
la capital ucraniana no oficial donde
hay calma como podíamos ver en el
reporte no de nuestra corresponsal pero
que se prepara para la guerra
así es rosa otro de los puntos claves en
esta guerra es el papel de china cuáles
son entonces la editorial es o mejor
dicho el editorial de el 'global times'
rosa pues sea china ha venido criticando
mucho no la postura de occidente y las
presunciones que hacen los medios
occidentales así como eeuu pero en este
editorial que dice que todo toda persona
pacífica espera que termine ya esta
guerra sangrienta pero dice estados
unidos y la otan podrían haber evitado
la guerra pero sólo añaden más leña al
fuego dice que considera que este
conflicto es una extensión de las
tensiones entre rusia y eeuu y que por
qué eeuu manda armamento en lugar de
sentarse a negociar directamente la paz
con rossi as revisemos en las
caricaturas rosa si hemos comentado
muchas caricaturas a lo largo de este
mes porque a veces amplifican muchos
mensajes complejos y aquí en este caso
hemos destacado la de james en the
gardian o dice la cara de la guerra y
dice pues sigue resistiendo no la cara
de putin pues un poco desgastado
destruido en rusia pero que continúa con
su invasión y cerramos con una
fotogalería del país exactamente es una
pues selección de 30 imágenes que
ilustran momentos claves momentos
horribles de este primer mes de guerra
vemos pues fotos de kharkiv la polilla
mariupol o de sal vivo ir bien algunas
fotos que han dado la vuelta al mundo
pero que les invitamos que entren a
consultar las pues en la página web de
este medio de comunicación así de rosa
muchísimas gracias nos vemos mañana con
más de revista de prensa pasamos a
saludar a nuestro primer invitado